é capuz e um jogo novo de tumores
prestar brutal por isso pegue as vossas
pipocas pessoal pega o vasco como time o
que quer o tottenham irá comer e vamos
embora cuja o gebo careca o lado sensual
aqui quem fala é o dado que sejam muito
bem vindos a mais de um vídeo e o
estrago sheik um jogo muito sendo que
acabou de sair foi ontem hoje já não
sair estamos aqui não só mastiga dos
mesmos criadores do nc posição deve tar
brutal da filha do ditador para caraças
ven andei pessoal embora lá novo jogo
realidade é aquilo que mesmo que fosse
parar de acreditar não vai embora
você estava em simão só pelo simão há
exatamente um acidente de carro
wall é muito alto léo está muito alto
aqui no meu ouvido op é um sonho minha
casa eu preciso ter um fluido a ok eu
preciso tomar o fluido para ficar num
dossier própria mesmo aparentemente
então eu tive mesmo acidente e agora
preciso de construir o meu cérebro e
coisas assim parece mover os técnicos
movimento da mulher saber se ele ainda
vem com jogos me ensinou a usar depois
saber não sabia dessa ainda está muito
rio está a ser hoje texturas tão brutais
até capaz tomaram café que sua
illuminati não sou illuminatis o
iluminado não sou iluminado iluminado
não sou iluminado ok o objetivo
principal agora encontrar qualquer coisa
pra tomar é o hotel que possui por dão
aqui o que é basicamente foi o começo e
com disse que sofre por mim por estar a
recuperar e etc
para entender uma consulta médica ainda
melhor logo com amor é nem a minha
mãezinha tem fãs a alguém eu acho que eu
sozinho neste mundo são as árvores não
podem jogar eu não sei ao certo a
história deste jogo eu acho que eu tenho
se um tema de ficção científica assim eu
posso mandar o apoia não consigo algo
que eu preciso e rápido
o doutor paraná espera isso ou livros
sobre o cérebro de coisas de sempre sou
muito inteligente eu sou amigo do doutor
é o o tac uma chave a ao exibir um
fluido primeiro monitor mais das coisas
meu deputado dentro de uma gaveta
qualquer ou aqui está o nosso fluido
meta estudo lá para dentro
adoro de fluidos para as leite light
qasab moedas faz todo o sentido eo outro
no comboio
tá muito realista o jogo aí que o mano
já estava ligado
tendo ou não eu não sei se atender eu
não sei que é o jazz resposta mente eu
vou ter com jeci depois né
se quiser ir ao médico primeiro mãe de
gol não me digo não fazem eu queria
conversar comigo e eu estamos no
hospital e agora aí está tudo escuro é
que vai para ser visto na luz né
assim sim doutorou se pela sua ajuda
um código agora eu duvido longe com tal
lugar eu não sei que é o davi longe
porque estavam ligadas a ele o doutor é
isso acho eu não parece estar aqui eu
preciso um colega né
será que tá numa destas pinturas será
que estarão surfar aqui está na planta
será instalada a porta não sai o tac o
código 25 01 é isso mesmo 25 01
finalmente eu tive que muito tempo vivem
investigar melhor as coisas né dottore
itajaí segundo entrar aqui
olá doutoras itajaí já pode arranjar o
cérebro não alguém fumando windows a eu
posso ser útil para lá para lá bem
melhor assim só resta uma porta na época
estavam todas fechadas
o doutor o lado todo mundo sabe a moeda
só que aí nós vamos ter que fazer um
texto no cérebro e tirar um monte com o
saneamento qualquer aí vamos lá eu
basicamente você vai e sentar e manel
vamos lá ver como é que o cérebro espero
que não tenhamos monsto confiarem de
doutor pela crédito fácil a família já
começou já estou com saias inteira
ae a emoção
já tá já fiquei sem cérebro eu sabia que
o convite a confiar nela ou o que
aconteceu
a região que perguntou isto numa sala
escura para entendimento que aconteceu
ficou de discutir isso não chega nada
vai o que aconteceu o doutor doutor o
que aconteceu por que não deixar tudo
muito escuro como o cérebro todo comido
ok ativa que qualquer coisa aqui que eu
não sei ao certo quem foi
ai não sendo os dias independente por
favor foi deputado por um local de
frente é que eu não lembro de ter estado
aqui eu quero ter uma coisa destas
consultas serviço insiram onito acessado
[Aplausos]
está o enem espera partir o vidro da
arca às vezes tem que pensar um
bocadinho neptuno perdido por onde é que
eu vou eu me encheu de tal maneira no
meu cérebro que o futebol é
transportável não posso encontrar lá o
mito como é que se chama estamos na
cozinha especial do demônio que eu posso
ver isto só máquinas velhas e educado
alguém pode explicar onde gostou alguém
pode explicar por que os constroem sua
máquina estão máquinas velhas é sucata
isso não vai fazer mal barkan
lá em cima de qualquer coisa lá em cima
- sério
ae o repórter o bota bora lá pessoal
venham comigo por um vídeo em full
screen nascer eu não conseguir sozinho
está muito assustador
eu não sei ao certo o que anda atrás de
mim mas este já está a começar a ajustar
a stemac nos todo o lado porque o google
pico não eu estou encantada agachado
porquê porque é uma dica pra andar
agachado parece estar tudo tranquilo não
vejo que este é o pior podem fazer é
você jovem embrulho de não saber o que
anda atrás vocês calma calma da arc
calma tudo para embarcar uma procura
sozinho pequeno calma cuja boa jogada e
foi atrás de mim mas para estimular
sempre inclui um chip que é que está o
chip é isso mesmo meu deus agora sim já
consiga abrir aquela porta é conseguir
conseguir
diga que importa no caí já tardia pelo
menos disso o ou nós estamos debaixo do
oceano que o mundo é isso que o pessoal
que nós estamos no espaço vamos avançar
acho que não há nada de importante ele
traz que temos em segurança na internet
faz sentido
chamo aqui dentro meu deus meu agora
pessoal agora parei vasco é galera com
que monstros lá de cima e vamos comer o
cool-er agora finalmente tenho uma coisa
pra trás uma máquina que são manual
[Música]
aí vem o demônio quero passar o que está
a passar a ai ai
é isso ai ai minha perna e eu não sei
pra onde ir mas corre a banda nunca
saber mais sobre cada ano
não não não é que não adianta que não
isto não isto não não não não estou
jogando
na infância em outra escala e uso destas
casa agora uma só opção
meu deus pude jogo é este
ai ai aquela coisa não deixa subir
aquela coisa não deixa eu ir embora vou
por onde eu eu pensei é porque é porque
o que fazer porque assim eu quero brutal
episódio em breve espero que vocês
tenham gostado deixou o favorito fique
bem e até a próxima
[Música]